One of the biggest factor that can
effect this is a tension,
for instance.
I mean,
if you do not pay attention to
something,
it's very unlikely that you will learn
what,
uh,
you have.
Uh,
what,
uh,
he just,
just so for instance,
just to make an example,
a,
I bet the many people may not have as
many of us remember what we did on
September 11th because you know,
there was a coincidence just if we paid
particular attention to or,
or what happened that day.
I bet that much less people will
remember what happened the day before or
two days before.
So that's attention is also is very,
very important.
Another factor that it is very important
that would be motivation to,
if you don't care about doing something,
he will not learn about.
If you are depressed or things like
that.
You will not learn what he,
uh,
what you just saw.
What you just did will not memorize what
you just did.
Obviously,
you need to be able to perceive the
stimulus.
If you cannot see no way that he will
remember us
or she's not here.
You cannot remember words,
so we need to be able to get through to
those,
uh,
those things.
This is the staff that we help
remembering of usually a,
those are not the only things because we
can monitor also to chemicals and uh,
uh,
two other ways.
Also memories and hopefully in the
future will be even better at that.
So we can also stimulate memory
chemical.
They,
what they do,
they,
they will work at the level of the
synaptic connection.
And since at the time or memory,
there is a chain of chemical reaction
and the level of signups and I came here
actually means the same as soon as a
protein enzyme molecules are activated.
What do we do?
We kind of forced the system artificial
through this chemical and so the
knowledge this chemicals to announce a,
to announce a memory and they will do
this very well in animals and hopefully
we'll be able to do it in people as
well.
How many chemicals that one can use to
enhance memory.
And there are many proteins that are
relevant to the process of learning and
memory.
For instance,
uh,
all chemicals that act on a particular
gene,
particular gene by the name of crab,
um,
that stimulate his gene and they came
out in several different ways are all
molecule that in animals work quite well
at enhancing memory
they had available.
But we can give an extra,
an additional amount.
What we do in with these chemicals,
we take advantage of knowledge or what
normally happens in nature and a little
bit push in this is ending diseases even
easier because sometime if in disease we
find out that one of this chemical is a
less,
uh,
in lower amount than what you would be
normally.
We just help the process by giving it
efficiently.